I see Mark Cuban can I hear Mark Cuban
moments away we're still trying to get
the audio there he is ready now mark
what's up Dan hi bud how are you doing
I'm I'm good
what do you been doing at home Oh a lot
of the same watching my kids run my life
and trying to pretend I'm still in
charge with my wife you know the usual
do your kids think you're cool no
absolutely not
now well wait you you own the Mavericks
you seem to have some money that's not
impressive to your kids Shark Tank come
on no they think they're cool I love
this story I know you've talked about
this before of flirting with running for
the presidency but you know you have to
take inventory with your family so first
of all was it real that you were
considering a run in 25 okay yeah and
then if your family voted for you to run
for the presidency would you have done
yes absolutely okay so take me at dinner
when you assuming is dinner and then you
everybody gets a vote yeah absolutely
and it was one of those things like okay
my wife and my oldest daughter like know
we've heard it we hear everybody
everybody's asking us don't even think
about it
and I'm like can we least take a vote
and everybody got everybody was no
except for my ten year old son he was on
the fence he's like but I think it would
be cool to have Secret Service well
that's a big commitment there but I was
wondering about that if you it wasn't it
wasn't an anonymous poll like you needed
a lobbyist on your side mark help me out
with this this bubble here of
understanding exactly what we're up
against because I have issues with it
but I'm called Danny downer here like
the NFL and college football everybody
just
zooms well it's the NFL and college
football we're gonna play football I
just I don't know I don't know if we
have a Rudy Gobert moment and then what
happens here mark I mean there's a lot
of uncertainty there's no question about
it
but you know every day we learn a little
bit more this is it all comes down to
the science and trying to do whatever we
can to keep everybody safe I think if
you look at your own home or what you're
doing there you know when you have a
controlled environment you feel safer
and as long as you know people adhere to
the program you know we hope we should
be okay you know it's when you get the
aberrational scenarios that we can't
anticipate that I think creates some
risk but I you know as long as
everybody's on board I think we can pull
it off are you gonna be there um I will
be there at least part of the time we're
shooting shark tank we're finally
opening up allowed to and allowed to
shoot shark tank so we're trying to
squeeze it all in I try to get the
mothership to allow us to shoot shark
tank since it's an ABC show at Walt
Disney World but we haven't been able to
pull that off yet we're talking to Mark
Cuban ease the Mavs owner
I saw a stat I don't know if you even
know this the best winning percentage
for an NBA team since 2001 is San
Antonio yep second one second yeah yeah
yeah I knew that
that's pretty impressive yeah you know
up until the last few years we're pretty
good but you know having a big tall
German guy certainly help yeah I mean I
screwed up some things letting Nash go
but overall didn't I give you grief
about getting rid of Nash back when you
got rid of me I at least do it to your
face Marc I don't you know if you and
we've talked about this before when you
were interested in buying a baseball
team but if you looked at this as a
businessman what's going on in baseball
if I had you have the the commissioner
and the head of the Players Association
and you're the arbitrator how could you
bring baseball back that made the most
sense and we're just talking financially
because I don't know health-wise how
we're gonna be but financially how would
you do it it's certainly from the out
appears to be a matter of trust and I
can understand why they don't trust them
no I mean look at my experiences with
them you know it was very much
particularly under bud selig it was
autocratic it was you know his way or
the highway and you know he give or take
draft picks away and so when somebody's
in you know when a business is run that
way and I don't know you know if the the
current folks are doing it the same way
but when it business is run that way
it's really hard to trust and the only
thing really you can do is open the
kimono and put all your economic
information on the table and let them
see exactly what's going on and that's
just not how baseball operates Adams
silver though has that trust on both
sides like it appears that way I mean
you do you think that he has that true
trust on both sides yeah I mean he's
very collaborative he's a great listener
he understands what the bigger picture
is not only just for the NBA but also
for our players and for the sport of
basketball of globally you know and I
think he takes on that responsibility
but he you know Adam is not set in his
ways it's not this is my way or the
highway he's very open to suggestions no
matter where they come from by the way
who would have been your running mate
if you're running for the Presidency you
available no no no you got that far
you'd have to wear a suit and tie every
day you couldn't do no that would be the
first thing I did sweat suit why not
commander and sweat suit Mark Cuban why
not the protest or at least kneeling
before the anthem I don't know if your
team has talked about this you got other
things to worry about but is there any
policy that you have as the owner of the
Mavs or the NBA has that would prevent
this from happening well the NBA has got
a policy that you're supposed to stand
and face the flag during the national
anthem but you know it like we're just
talking Adam is very collaborative
minded and you know this is a
once-in-a-generation opportunity for us
to really impact American society and
change how minorities and
african-americans in particular are
treated and so I don't think you stand
on legacy items you know to you when you
have such an amazing opportunity and you
know I haven't had the discussion with
our players about this but you know this
is their league they they drive this
league a hundred percent and you know
I'm gonna be very supportive because
again you know when the pandemic first
hit and we closed down basketball
tonight we were playing that was bigger
than the NBA that was the state to
health and safety
you know now this is bigger than the NBA
as well and so we have you know the
players have a platform to get to really
show what's important to them and
hopefully have an impact on race
relations in this come in this country
and so again that's that's far more
important than you know some rules that
were established in the 80s that may not
be relevant today I wanted to quote you
correctly are you planning on kneeling
um you know I don't know if I'll be
allowed to be down by the floor but if I
can show if I can be act in unison and
show support for our players I'll
certain well what do you make a kyrie
irving's come in here mark I don't know
I mean you have to ask Kyrie on that I'm
sure he's got his logic I just I I don't
know Kyrie and all I haven't spoken when
you realize that your star player was
out of shape did you place a phone call
to your star player oh no I knew Luka
was working out that stuff about him
being out of shape yeah you know cuz we
Luke and I text all the time and he's
really proud to show me his workout
pictures really proud and up Luke is
lifting weights he's taking pictures
trust me waiting so when you get selfies
you know and your wife said oh what do
you got oh it's a selfie and it's
actually hey I got somebody with their
shirt off oh no it's Luca but how did it
come out that he was not in shape I
think there was a mistranslation he's
not in game shape but he's a good shape
that's good hey it's great what do you
have behind you you got
one thing that's hanging and then one
thing it's not oh this is my little
shark tank poster so I always guessed
the thing that's been up there for a
long time
other than the trophy what would impress
me the most about your your memorabilia
um
probably when I first bought the Mavs in
the first all-star game I went to
Julie's Serbia was my hero growing up in
Pittsburgh when I was a little kid I
mean I literally went to the film you
know the fish it's so one of my favorite
pictures is a picture of me standing
away from Julius Erving and one of my
friends taking a picture so it looks
like you've since spoken to dr. J did
you tell him about that yeah absolutely
B fish that saved Pittsburgh
yes that was they filmed a Civic Arena
when I was a kid and I took the 41 B bus
down to downtown Pittsburgh and I snuck
in through the back door and I wasn't an
extra did sign up but I was watching in
the wings while they were filming and
I'm just so excited that's great it's
great to talk to you and hopefully we
know this season started but I do think
football is got some question marks here
at least you guys got a head start with
this bubble well we'll find out you know
you know and but everybody's learning
every day you know and we'll see what
happens because the other thing Dan I'll
mention real quick this isn't just about
the NBA if we can't pull this off what a
college basketball in high school
basketball and middle school basketball
going to do and who you know we are
going to be the template for them in a
lot of respects on the things we learn
and what we can communicate to everybody
downstream so again this is another
situation where it's bigger than just
that the NBA and it's bigger than just
basketball but do you think that you
know the teams that worked hard to get a
home court advantage won't have a home
court advantage were you in favor of
giving these teams anything
that really wasn't even a topic of
conversation you know at least any of
the conversations that I was in it was
more about the bigger picture you know
how can we do this safely and again well
the man has had the number one seed with
that what if the Mavs had the number one
seed
I'd be like we got to play all the games
well I did wonder this mark and I I
don't know like can we get could we've
gotten to the point where the Eastern
Conference in Western Conference teams
played each other or maybe just the
finals played each other and then so
they were traveling there instead of
staying in Orlando in this bubble you
know we have to listen to the scientists
who tell us what to do and how to do it
the one thing we can't compromise on is
doing our best to keep everybody safe
and so you know the more you travel the
more people involved the more locations
of all the more difficult it is so I
think we we came up with the right
approach and we'll learn you know and
then we'll just cross our fingers and
hope that we get a vaccine so by the
time next season rolls along we'll have
you know more ammunition to try to deal
with this
will there be an asterisk attached to
this season no no more than 1999
everybody said there'd always be an
asterisk you know no one remembers I
said that to people I go you know when
the the Spurs won the title there was no
ask nobody brings that up at all and
they go wait what happened where even
the Europe you know 2012 when it was a
66 game post lockout season yeah right
no one brought that up and that was a
big deal because you were playing back
to back to back games to get 66 games
into a season and so that was even more
difficult and so you know no people
don't look at that people just look at
the rings on your finger once again he
led Steve Nash get away he's due think
Nash has moved on from it he's he's all
I can we kind of we kind of put it
behind as we went out and had a couple
drinks one day and I think we got past
it but Phoenix had kid
KJ and Nash on the roster at the same
time right yeah yep Wow I can't imagine
what practice must have been like for
those guys hey thanks for joining us
good luck with shark tank as always and
be safe thank you Mark